كما قلنا بالفعل عدة
مرات ، هذا هو أسوأ وقت في اليوم
ليس فقط للمشاة ولكن من حيث حركة المرور ، وفقط
احتمال الخطر
هنا هو فقط من خلال السقف الذي
يتباطأ مقارنةً بالسابق ولكن لا يزال أه
يقود بشكل متقطع جدًا و  التوجيه
مباشرة حول أي شخص في طريقه لا
يحترم ذلك الضوء الأحمر الذي يمر عبر
ذلك تمامًا وكذلك Crossing Hill
Street and Here Come تلك الوحدات التي خلفه
يمكنك أن ترى تلك الوحدة الأساسية التي
يعتقد أنها 605 أو أنا آسف على
أه الـ 710  الطريق السريع أه هنا في
الأميال القليلة القادمة
إذا ذهب طوال الطريق لقد حصلت على
اه بعض المشاكل المختلطة في أذني يا
رفاق
لا يمكنهم سماعي بشكل صحيح ، يا
إلهي ، انظروا إلى هذا المشتبه به أنه
يركض دون المسدس يركض بدون
المسدس سوف يأخذونه إلى الأسفل
هنا ، إنه الآن في شارع ويسترن أفينيو ، يا
إلهي ، يا إلهي ، إنه يسير على الأقدام
يركب سيارة ، شخص آخر يحاول
سرقة شخص
أجنبي
هناك ، نذهب
أه أه
واحد على خمسة ،
fm1 على أربعة fm2 قيد التشغيل  خمسة
مجلدات نعم
أه كلاهما يقول إيكوم
أه سلبي انتهى